[Musique]
au nord-ouest des etats-unis au milieu
des montagnes de l'orégon un village
tranquille et propret
c'est dans cette maison cossue que nous
rencontrons téti 32 ans qui s'apprête à
prendre un tout nouveau départ elle a
pris une décision radicale dans quelques
jours elle quittera tout son confort
pour une aventure hors norme tu fais
comment pour le mettre au milieu c'est
très bien mais tu peux aller beaucoup
plus
rétives à changer de vie elle est en
train d'équiper cette camionnette sa
nouvelle demeure avec l'aide de travis
qu'elle a rencontré sur un forum elle
s'apprête à rejoindre une communauté qui
ne cesse de grandir aux états unis ce
qui largue tout pour vivre dans un
fourgon aménagé
jolie
loin de la société de consommation sa
vie va désormais tenir dans cet
utilitaire ses ennemis elle les passera
sur solide quand on dirait palmer s'il
est vraiment confortable
cuisine ni d'eau courante elle terminera
l'aménagement de sa camionnette en route
avec les outils qu'elle emportait
tout rentre dans ce panier c'est un
panier à othis
c'est un sacré défi
je ne sais pas ça va être un gros défi
c'est sûr ce sera au milieu de nulle
part mais ça va être marrant
je suis vraiment fière d'elle elle est
très travailleuse elle a fait un travail
extraordinaire
cet expert comptable a choisi la liberté
elle a mis un terme à ses rêves de
carrière de propriété de croissance et
de consommation
le truc essentiel c'est le shampoing sec
elle a prévu d'en porter dans ses
valises le strict minimum
une petite révolution pour cette
diplômée habitué au confort d'une vie
bourgeoise
à l'université j'avais 100 paires de
chaussures c'était absurde
à cette époque je vais acheter tout ce
que je voulais pas d'où ce t-shirt
différent de toutes les couleurs
c'était tellement pas nécessaire dans
mon bonheur ne repose pas sur ce que je
possède c'est ce que j'ai compris
donc quelques jours elle sera sur la
route elle va rejoindre le grand
mouvement du van lines en français la
vie en camionnette courir le monde
prendre la tangente vagabonder et
voyager toute l'année dans des paysages
sublimes les grands espaces américains
un décor de cinéma beaucoup rêvent mais
eux ont sauté le pas leurs photos
donnent le vertige sur les réseaux
sociaux ils génèrent des millions de
clics et de dollars cette génération de
nomades auto entrepreneur est ultra
connectés
les vans leifer veulent profiter de la
vie loin des exigences et des
contraintes de la société contemporaine
[Musique]
je ne me suis pas épilée légende depuis
un an et je n'y pense pas
particulièrement
il rêve de grands espaces d'une vie en
autonomie
peut-être que je suis naïve mais je ne
m'inquiète pas pour ma sécurité
cette quête de liberté attire aussi des
familles avec enfants
non
notre génération elle se dit qu'elle
peut vivre et travailler sur la route
profitez des voyages sans attendre la
retraite pour se faire plaisir
les seniors déjà grands parents ont tout
aussi été piqué par le virus des
aventuriers qui cherche le grand frisson
avec le confort de vannes de luxe ce
genre de situation lisez moi c'est
vraiment ce qu'on préfère
un fourgon pour toute maison et la route
comme unique futur aux etats unis le
phénomène vannes life prend une ampleur
phénoménale
ils seraient des dizaines de milliers à
avoir déjà fait ce choix loin de tous
traits de l'essentiel telle est leur
devise
sont ils en train de créer un nouveau
mode de vie
[Musique]
un nouveau rêve américain
chaque année c'est une ville roulante
éphémères qui s'installent dans une
plaine de l'orégon dans le nord-ouest
des etats-unis
ça sent le vent de l'ajfer pas très
propre et free venez nous voir on va
vous donner une bonne douche
les vans leifer comme ils s'appellent ce
sont ses habitants des camionnettes
pendant trois jours un millier d'entre
eux se retrouvent pour faire une pause
sur leur route et partager leurs
expériences
à 30,2 en corée et l'inde ces voyageurs
à plein temps cela fait six ans qu'il
est sur la route cet ancien guide de
kayak est l'un des pionniers du
mouvement
ça vu comment ça va ils n'ont pas l'air
comme ça mais avant de tout largué il
avait une vie plus conventionnelle
si tu rencontres des gens qui n'ont pas
plus de 20 $ aux poches et d'autres qui
vivent dans des vans qui coûte 200 mille
dollars
il n'y a pas de profil type
tu peux avoir des hippies assis à côté
d'un officier de carrière
leur icône c'est ce célèbre camion des
années 60 le combi volkswagen le symbole
vintage de leur vie nomade un habitat
que ses propriétaires adapte au gré de
leurs pérégrinations
tu m'as dit que tu avais un poil dans
ton van je peux le voir
il marche qui perd bien et ne prend pas
beaucoup de place et on but c'est de
vivre à la montagne tout l'hiver oui je
serai dans le colorado pour faire du
snowboard ça devrait me tenir chaud
[Musique]
on les retrouve si on instagram fiers de
leur nouvelle vie dans un cadre toujours
enchanteur
il y as lease une ancienne présentatrice
de journaux télévisés qui vit désormais
dans un camion brittany et son petit ami
zhu qui vendait des montres de luxe
avant de partir sur la route
ou encore david un ingénieur en réseau
électrique qui gagnait quatre vingt
mille euros par an et qui a tout plaqué
pour faire de l'escaladé aux quatre
coins de l'amérique
un choix qui n'est pas toujours facile à
faire accepter par leur entourage
[Musique]
tu as quel âge 19 ans étaient parents
mes parents
ma mère n'en ai aucune idée elle fit
près tout le temps mais tu sais il faut
juste franchir le pas et se lancer dans
l'aventuré et même si tes parents et tes
potes disent que c'est stupide de
quitter l'école
avec ses amis corps et cultive le goût
de l'aventuré hors des sentiers battus
et commence à 20h salle à etoy il a
contribué à faire connaître le mouvement
grâce à son blog avec ses photos de
voyages qui connaît un succès
grandissant
le monde connaît son blog et tu sais tu
peux devenir une célébrité sur instagram
mais corée n'a jamais pris la grosse
tête il est hyper abordable
vas-y continue
le site qui l'animent et suivie par près
de 200 mille personnes
avec sa petite amie emilie et leurs deux
chiens il attire des annonceurs qui
cherchent à profiter de leur notoriété
pour toucher un public jeune sur les
réseaux sociaux
les vans leifer influents comme eux
parviennent à vivre de leur image et à
financer leur vie nomade
malgré leur apparence de keep it cool
ils n'ont pas perdu le sens des affaires
[Musique]
en
quelques semaines plus tard nous
retrouvons courait dans le même l'un des
états les plus sauvages d'amérique au
nord de new york
[Musique]
sa petite amie emilie
était responsable marketing
avant de devenir un business le van nuys
se veut une philosophie du voyage
minimaliste et respectueuse de
l'environnement
[Musique]
les graines de courge des graines de
tournesol là on peut en rajouter
emilie et corées vont explorer l'état du
maine pendant dix jours
avant chaque départ ils font toutes
leurs courses dans des coopératives bio
un petit sacrifice car leur budget est
limité
si on prenait des pistaches
bon c'est un peu cher
acheter du bio pour moi ce n'est pas
seulement se nourrir mieux avec de beaux
légumes
c'est aussi faire attention à notre
planète
il achète tout en vrac en utilisant ces
boîtes pour limiter les emballages 25
dollars 93 ans une vingtaine d'euros
pour quelques jours de vivre presque pas
de dépenses de l'amour et de l'eau
fraîche chaque jour et voyage sur la
route en décidant souvent leur
destination à la dernière minute mais
avant de partir ils vont réaliser une
photo car au pays du vin life
l'esthétique est primordial pour espérer
gagner de l'argent je vais sortir les
chiens
ils ont choisi ce cadre idyllique au
bord de la mer
fait une marque l'épée près de 1000
euros par mois pour s'afficher
régulièrement avec ce terme hausse sur
leur compte instagram
cette entreprise nous aident à financer
nos voyages être en mesure de partager
nos expériences en ligne avec notre
public
si c'était juste pour l'argent on ne
ferait pas ça on n'est pas riche vous
savez
oui c'est vraiment pour vivre une autre
aventure
et ça nous aide sur le plan financier
mais on aurait vraiment du mal à vivre
dans un appartement ou une maison avec
l'argent qu'on gagne
les marques sont prêtes à les payer car
ces deux modèles amateurs sont très
doués pour jouer de leur image
j'aime bien cette photo il passe des
heures à choisir et à retoucher les
clichés
[Musique]
je la trouve un peu jaune en
arrière-plan
chacune de leurs photos de rêve attire
des milliers de clics 3000 ont tout pour
celle ci cela ressemble à des vacances
mais pour eux c'est un travail à part
entière
nous on ne voyait pas l'intérêt de
s'endetter énormément très jeune pour
s'acheter une maison et on pouvait pas
se le permettre
on a décidé de faire différemment
et on s'est dit que ce serait plus sympa
de voyager
mais c'est clair qu'on leur jette pas la
société capitaliste
non on n'essaye pas d'échapper au
travail
il est clair pour nous que la vie c'est
du boulot et que c'est pas toujours rose
en moyenne à eux deux ils gagnent un peu
plus de 2000 euros par mois mais il ne
dépense presque rien
il y en a pour deux heures et demie
pour les prochains jours ils ont décidé
d'aller découvrir un sommet de la région
la fin de l'automne leur offre des
paysages sublimes
mais émilie ne lâche jamais son
téléphone une marque de bière vient de
leur proposer un nouveau contrat
écoute ça ne me convient pas je ne sais
pas vraiment si on doit s'impliquer là
dedans
avec nos valeurs
tu vois là on va dire non un contrat de
2400 $ pour trois fois et demi
emilie enregistre tout leur vie sur les
réseaux sociaux est devenu une source de
revenus une façon de financer leur choix
nomades
sur la route ils sont libres de leur
temps libre d'aller où bon leur semble
quand ils veulent à l'heure où toute
l'amérique se met au travail c'est super
nous partons excursions c'est vraiment
le moment idéal il y a de la neige
partout mais encore des feuilles sur les
arbres
trois heures balade est au sommet emilie
et corps et sont récompensés de leurs
efforts un endroit idéal pour une photo
tu vas être trompé
je le suis déjà
la lumière du soir est idéal parfait
pour faire rêver leurs abonnés la vanne
attitude ce biais ce poste
frénétiquement
le cliché rapidement apprécié par 2400
internautes contribuer à leur renommée
c'est ce que cherchent les annonceurs
qui les contactent
le soir venu ils installent leur
campement dans le parc national
emilie et corey auront toute la forêt
pour russell cette niche
nous sommes dans la forêt d'un parc
national dans le new hampshire des
forêts comme ça il y en a dans tous les
états unis et il autorise le camping
sauvage vous pouvez rester jusqu'à 14
jours c'est gratuit et c'est magnifique
en six ans emilie et corée ont appris à
vivre simplement avec moins de 60 euros
par jour dans leur van il y a le strict
nécessaire
comment vous faites pour cuisiner dans
ce petit espace
c'est un peu le bazar gens mais un peu
partout et corey râlent toujours dans
ces cas là
il ya des pelures d'oignon des morceaux
d'oignons
des traces de gras un peu partout donc
c'est un peu compliqué mais tu peux y
arriver ça fond était au bord
corps et le dîner prête
à la tienne
ce soir il fait 0 degré emilie a les
pieds encore trompé mais il garde le
sourire
à partir du moment où vous avez des bons
vêtements lé bon sac de couchage
et les deux chiens
penny dégage
fais-moi de la place je suis fatigué à
les pénibles
leurs vielles vannes est très mal isolé
les chiens serviront de radiateur
[Musique]
comme presque chaque matin le couple se
réveille dans un écrin de verdure
emilie s'élever la première
pour aller méditer
[Musique]
je me sens comme chez moi dans mon
élément je me sens comme si j'étais un
petit enfant
cette liberté qui me rappellent mes 8
ans quand j'allais courir dans les bois
et que je jouais dans mon jardin secret
depuis six ans emilie commencent toutes
ces journées comme ça ce qui était
impossible dans sa vie d'avant
elle affirme que son rapport au corps et
à la féminité échappent aujourd'hui au
coeur d'imposer par la société
en vivant dans un van j'ai libéré la
femme sauvage qui était en moi
j'ai arrêté d'accorder de l'importance à
ce que les gens pensaient de moi
et ça a commencé par quelque chose
d'aussi simple que d'arrêter de m'épiler
les gendres
j'ai commencé à me sentir plus à l'aise
avec ce que mon corps est naturellement
la personne que je suis
et donc oui je ne me suis pas épilée
depuis un an mais je n'y pense même pas
ces poses inspirées dans des cadres
sublime sont très suivis sur internet
mais ce qui a contribué à sa notoriété
elle en est bien consciente ce sont ces
photos dénudées quel poste sans
complexes souvent avec les produits
d'une marque comme le fameux thermos qui
la paye à chaque publication
oui c'est vrai que ça attire plus de
clics donc il ya un côté business parce
qu'évidemment c'est un business vous
savez j'ai étudié le marketing donc je
comprends que ça génère plus de vues sur
internet mais je ne vois rien de mal à
cela parce que ce n'est pas en
contradiction avec ce que je suis
cool mais pragmatique avec le sens des
affaires elle assume sa stratégie c'est
à ce prix qu'elle peut continuer cette
vie qu'elle n'abandonnerait pour rien au
monde
ketty est encore loin de cette routine
dans la maison familiale de l'orégon la
jeune voyageuse solo va prendre la route
elle va quitter ses parents qui sont
très mal à l'aise façon choix de leur
fils
tu es prête à partir prête à partir tu
as peu inquiet de savoir toujours celle
dans le van ils ont fait fortune dans
l'industrie et ne comprennent pas le
projet de ketty loin de leur réveil
un virage à 180 degrés pour elle
il ya quelques années elle habite un
appartement de standing elle dirigeait
un bureau
fraîchement diplômé de la fac elle a
acheté une maison dans l'orégon pour la
rénover
jardiner elle a même refait la cuisine
elle avait plein de projets
et puis elle a eu cette idée
moi je trouve pas ça normal
vivre sans douche sans toilettes
pour moi c'est étrange
je suis super têtu mais ça me touche
qu'il s'inquiète pour moi
moi je ne pense pas fuir je cherche
juste à faire ce qui me rend heureuse
on l'a fait trop indépendante
[Rires]
attention à toi
[Applaudissements]
à l'opposé de cette vie toute tracée
elle a décidé de partir au moins un an
voire plus si l'expérience est
concluante
dans son voyage en quête du bonheur elle
n'apporte qu'une petite valise et sa
chienne sophie
[Musique]
elle n'a pas d'itinéraire précis ketty a
rassemblé toutes ses économies 25000
euros pendant son voyage à l'espère
gagnée ce dont elle a besoin en
travaillant comme photographe pour des
mariages elle verra bien
je suis super excité je suis comme une
gosse à la veille de la rentrée
c'est vraiment un changement d'avis je
vais créer une maison et chaque jour
sera une expérience différente
vivre seule dans une camionnette sans
isolation son confort un saut dans
l'inconnu pour cet ancien cadre
tu peux jamais savoir situé dans un
endroit sécurisé pour passer la nuit
c'est l'un des inconvénients
pour sa première nuit elle a demandé à
son ami travis de l'accompagner il après
7 dans son fourgon
oui je suis là c'est un bon endroit
puisse arrêter des routes de terre
déserte au milieu de la forêt à une
heure au moins du village le plus proche
désormais c'est dans ce genre d'endroit
isolée qu'elle passera ses nuits
en attendant d'avoir une cuisine elle
dîne dans le 20ème de son ami
santé oui tu es enfin sur la route
félicitations d'en être arrivé là
merci pour ton aide tu sais pour mon
premier voyage le sol était à peine
terminée et j'avais juste et un mac qui
pendait entre ces deux murs je suis
heureuse à l'idée de me réveiller demain
au milieu de nulle part
un lit de camp et un sac de couchage un
peu léger pour supporter le froid
elle n'a pas tout prévu et va découvrir
la vie vannes life de façon brutale
[Musique]
le soleil se lève son la vallée de krups
river ranch et pour sa première nuit
katie n'a pas beaucoup dormi
ce matin j'ai eu froid à 4 ou 5 heures
du matin je me suis réveillé j'étais je
lai châu
à 1200 mètres d'altitude les
températures ont atteint -5 degrés pas
de douche désormais elle va devoir se
contenter de geler et de shampoing sec
mais c'est ce qu'elle est venue chercher
[Musique]
quand tu te réveilles et que tu
n'entends que le bruit de l'eau c'est si
paisible à j'adore
c'est un style de vie différent
je pense que donne plus de chances de
tlv personnellement je n'ai pas
sollicité en permanence
par les réseaux sociaux donc cette force
a profité du monde extérieur et de la
nature
[Musique]
ce nouveau style de vie qui séduit de
plus en plus d'américains a fait
exploser le marché du van de loisirs il
est aujourd'hui en pleine croissance
plus de 10% par an aux états unis
à fresno au centre de la californie un
entrepreneur passionné en profite
pleinement
comment ça va ça va merci johnny dans
l'arrière boutique je penserai
à l'aune field a fait fortune en
aménageant des camionnettes de luxe avec
son fils johnny comment tu vas mec ça va
super vous avez l'air occupé oui on a
pas mal de boulot
la société d feld a été créée dans les
années 60 c'est la plus ancienne des
états unis dans ce domaine aujourd'hui
elle réalise plusieurs millions de
dollars de chiffre d'affaires les
clients viennent de tout le pays pour
leurs commandes et des camionnettes sur
mesure
regardez la tablette est retenu par un
petit aimant et elle se détache comme ça
c'est superbe
pour communiquer surtout que ces options
d'aménagement la société créer des
vidéos qui sont vu des milliers de fois
sur internet
ici vous pourrez voir qu'il ya
énormément de place à l'intérieur de ce
van la partie couchage dispose d'une vue
à 360 degrés
on peut tout voir autour et le siège du
passager peut même se retourner
[Musique]
bonjour je suis joël comment allez-vous
aujourd'hui bien je suis daniel bonjour
je suis maria
on a regardé sur youtube instagram
on pense à y vivre à plein temps
on vient en californie et on cherche à
changer
il faudra vendre votre maison mais comme
ça on sera plus lire
ici tout est possible que vous installez
une salle de bain de 83 cm de large même
un plus de 100000 euros ce couple semble
déjà emballée alors vous êtes prêt à
renoncer au confort de waldemar
kita petit on s'est laissé avoir le
voyage c'est l'argument principal
oui parce qu'on a commencé dans la vie
avec une maison avec deux chambres
ensuite on a déménagé dans une maison
avec quatre chambres mais on a cette
envie de voyager alors on s'est dit
pourquoi pas ramener la maison alors on
veut juste vendre notre maison et tous
nos biens et s'installer dans un van
chaque camion est aménagé sur mesure les
clients peuvent demander les options les
plus folles comme pour ceux vannes il y
en a pour six mille dollars rien qu'en
sonorisation
là tu as des enceintes au plafond le son
dolby surround une télé 50 cm
et c'était quoi les demandes les plus
folles un mec voulait une barre de pole
dance un autre une station ou pêche sur
glace on a dû percer un trou dans le van
pour que le mec puisse se garer au
milieu d'un lac gelé et pêcher avec le
chauffage allumé j'suis pas sûr que
c'était une bonne idée un véhicule de
cinq tonnes au milieu de la glace
imaginez si c'est légal on le fera si
c'est illégal faut qu'on en parle et on
vous fera pas de facture c'est tout
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
aux quatre coins des états unis les
vannes leifer rivalisent de bricolage et
d'imagination pour construire la maison
roulante la plus attrayante ou la plus
pratique il y a le genre caravane en
bois massif
le vans façon salon bourgeois
l'option cuisine démontable la salle de
sport déployables ou même le cinéma
ambulant
aujourd'hui alan va découvrir leurs
dernières créations
ouais c'est magnifique j'adore la
peinture
1,22 haut standing en fibre de verre
avec peinture inrayable il y en a pour
cent soixante dix mille euros le prix
d'une petite maison
la boîte de vitesses à deux leviers tu
peux passer en 4 roues motrices gamme
basse ou gamme haute ou deux roues avant
motrices c'est un véhicule de l'extrême
pour le tout terrain l'équivalent d'un
véhicule de l'armée mais en version
aménagée
ces derniers temps la production est
débordé une centaine de camions aménagés
et un carnet de commandes plein pour les
mois à venir du jamais vu
salut comment ça va bravo pour ton bébé
merci merci il va falloir lui offrir un
van
tout est plein jusqu'au 16 septembre
avant on en a semblé trois ou quatre par
semaine maintenant c'est plus 4 5 6 par
semaine donc ça progresse vous pensez qu
instagram les réseaux ont contribué à
cet essor
instagram et les réseaux sociaux n'ont
pas fait de mal c'est sur ces cinq
dernières années les vannes sont devenus
populaires et branché grâce à un
mouvement one life
à 60 ans à l'ana transmis l'entreprise à
son fils désormais lui aussi passe le
plus clair de son temps à voyager devant
son immense villa sont 24 4 est toujours
prêt à partir
il garde sa maison pour recevoir ses
petits enfants quand lui et sa femme
reviennent de virer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais qui est là
comment vous avez fait pour devenir si
grande
les filles vous allez venir quand tu es
avec nous non non vous allez rester ici
guan deux ans et olivia 4 on ne voit
plus que très rarement leurs grands
parents les deux jeunes retraités
pasquet trois quart de leur temps sur la
route
le plus dur quand on est constamment en
train de bouger et de voyager c'est que
nos petites filles nous manque
donc en rentre toutes les quatre cinq
semaines pour les voir
johnny a dû se faire à l'idée qu'à 60
ans ses parents avaient une envie de
prendre le large à la moindre occasion
c'est top je suis même un peu jaloux je
veux partir et vivre dans un van mais
moi je suis bloqué avec les enfants et
les horaires de bureau avec toutes ses
obligations je ne suis pas libre d'aller
où je veux ouais je suis un peu envieux
et bien écoute ta qu'a faire comme nous
je veux être un bon exemple pour mes
enfants on a travaillé extrêmement dur
pendant 30 ou 40 ans tu sais parfois on
travaille et 90 jours d'affilée pendant
les expositions de vannes cette vie
c'est le fruit d'un travail acharné je
pense qu'ils peuvent le comprendre
ouais mais perdre nos baby sitter c'est
dur
à chaque départ c'est la même chose et
petite fille d'alan élise n'arrive pas à
laisser partir leurs grands parents
ok ok bisous
alan elle réalise que vous partez
[Musique]
le couple part quelques semaines
s'échapper en californie
ils vont voyager à leur manière dans un
van à 150000 euros avec des aménagements
digne d'une limousine
une des choses qu'on prend sans faute
c'est notre petit bard dépliants on a
notre vin français là dedans
on vit dans un van quatre roues motrices
dans des conditions extrêmes mais on
aime nos équipements de luxe
on emporte aussi beaucoup d'équipement
de survie
on a eu 2 h une fusée de détresse
des chaînes des câbles de remorquage
vous n'êtes pas un vandale fer ordinaire
ah non on va là où la plupart des vannes
ne vont pas
[Musique]
rouler dans les endroits les plus
extrêmes c'est ça qui attire cet expert
de la conduite en vannes
bonjour bienvenue au parc yosemite
bonjour bienvenue dans les montagnes
merci
ils partent traverser un grand parc
national américain lone yosemite qui
fait la taille d'un département français
[Musique]
ça vous fait quoi d'être à nouveau sur
la route
oh j'adore
je me sens bien c'est bien mieux que
d'être à la maison devant la télé
des routes tortueuses parfois même
dangereuse au détour d'un virage un
accident vient de se produire
ça va vous allez bien
ces touristes indiens ont percuté un
rocher avec leur voiture
ils ont eu la chance avec les airbags
qu'est ce qui s'est passé
qu'est ce que c'est c'est du fromage
encore sous le choc la passagère s'en
sort avec une brûlure au front et un
poignet tordu
mais alan est conscient que son mode de
vie peut l'exposer à de nombreux dangers
dans quelques heures le couple sera
livré à lui-même loin de la civilisation
ça peut vraiment mal tourné si tu n'es
pas préparé non on a plusieurs trousse
de secours fait par des médecins avec de
coire à coudre des plaies
car si ce genre d'accident se produit
dans la vallée de la mort tu peux
attendre trois à quatre heures avant que
les secours n'arrivent
à plus le nom de notre 26 rappel c'est
un ange gardien
à l'analyse repartent car le meilleur
reste à voir avant la tombée de la nuit
le parc de yosemite avec ses milliers de
lacs et de cours d'eau ces forêts de
cèdres qui abrite des ours bruns
alan regarde c'est tellement beau
avec son 4 4 le couple part à l'assaut
d'un col périlleux
ici pas le réseau mobile pat secours
alors alan reste très concentré sur sa
conduite
mais ça va être dur
attends tu va beaucoup trop vite là à
mon goût j'ai essayé en le prenant d'un
autre angle laisse moi regarder je vais
vérifier attends attends attends
attends non mais c'est bon je sors là
il s'engage avec précaution guidé par sa
copilote
le passage est délicat mais pas de quoi
effrayer ses retraités devenu expert
dans les rallyes de montagne
je suis au top je reste en forme je fais
du sport tout le temps
je vais leur montrer aux jeunes que les
vieux aussi peuvent s'amuser
qu'on est en train de faire la lisent et
moir on s'éclate on adore faire ça
après une journée de route il s'enfonce
sur ce chemin est inaccessible à la
plupart des véhicules
ils vont s'arrêter là
dans cette plaine sauvage au milieu des
montagnes
[Musique]
il n'y a personne à moins de 100 km le
bonheur pour le couple qui installe en
2de un restaurant avec une vue
imprenable et un menu digne d'une table
étoilée
on va manger du thon rouge puis en aller
retour avec une sauce wasabi au soja
accompagné d'un riz aux oignons et aux
champignons avec des courgettes grillées
et pour sublimer le tout un bon vin
français
ça n'a pas l'air très pratique serait
pas mieux chez vous
oui mais je n'ai pas cette vue dans ma
maison
le coucher de soleil qu'il y a juste là
jusqu'au lever demain matin ça fait
partie de l'aventuré on est là pour ça
et puis quand on quand on a faim tout le
temps alors nos plats paraissent bien
meilleure
santé santé shérif le couple comp et
voyage en amoureux depuis plus de 40 ans
eux aussi ont été van lier sans le sou
quand on était plus jeune et con
campaient on mangeait des hot-dogs des
hamburgers des chips
maintenant qu'on vieillit
et bien on veut manger plus sain car on
veut faire ça pendant longtemps encore
ces nouveaux nomades ou fait du voyage
un élixir de jouvence
ici c'est la liberté je me sens libéré
des contraintes matérielles mais
non j'ai pas besoin de si j'ai pas
besoin de ça dans le van j'ai juste le
nécessaire
une nuit dans la nature comme luxe
ultime
il y a des moments magiques et les jours
de pluie moins drôle le vans live tout
d'un coup quand on est coincé dans un
habitacle de poche retour sur la côte
est avec corey et emilie les voyageurs
star d'internet qui ont choisi de dormir
ce soir dans un vrai lit à l'abri
vous êtes trompés
[Musique]
maria la mère de corey les accueille
dans le confort de sa maison bien
chauffé
malgré leur vie nomade le couple tient à
maintenir des liens forts avec la
famille et les amis ch
même si ce sont de grands enfants des
adultes on est vraiment content de les
avoir à la maison on prend des nouvelles
d'eux de leur chien ce sont de vrais
bons moments
et en plus ce sont de très bons
cuisiniers
pour nous c'est essentiel de revenir
régulièrement dans la région où on a
grandi et de se retrouver avec notre
famille c'est une sensation qu'on ne
peut pas trouver sur la route
je sais ce qu'il manque de la noix de
muscade
vraiment
entre deux voyages corée et emilie reste
parfois soufflé ici plusieurs semaines
en profitant de la générosité de leurs
parents
au début quand ils nous ont annoncé leur
nouvelle vie on savait pas combien de
temps ça allait durer mais on les
supporte totalement parce qu'ils ont
réussi à construire un projet et faire
ce qui leur plaît
on continue à les voir et à faire partie
de leur vie mais parfois les retrouve
même sur la route et en partagent un
goût de leur aventure oui il se sent
vraiment très reconnaissant d'avoir des
parents aussi compréhensif bon je dois
financer mon fils alors je vais bosser
demain qu'est ce que vous avez dit
mais c'est pas vrai il faut pas que ce
soit dans le film c'est pas vrai
[Rires]
car à demain ils reprendront la route
cette nuit là ils dormiront au chaud et
au sec
[Musique]
cette vie de voyages de plus en plus de
couples avec enfants l'attend
aujourd'hui aux états unis ils n'ont pas
peur de se lancer sur les routes en
famille c'est ce qu'ont fait les fit au
nord de la floride
[Musique]
dans la famille il y a le père la mare
la maman ashley
le chien beyrouth et enfin et wehrli une
petite fille de 4 ans ils ont bâti un
petit studio roulant avec un grand lit
pour les parents in touch est à part
pour leur enfant qui apprend à compter
en voyageant
2 3 4
nous avons décidé de vivre en vannes
après avoir fait un voyage dans 47 états
du pays
nous avons fait ce voyage dans une
petite voiture et après on s'est dit que
ce serait quand même mieux si on avait
un van
il y a deux ans ils ont vendu leur
maison pour s'offrir ce camion ils ont
participé à une émission de télé réalité
le concept des couples comme se font
filmer à chaque étape de la construction
de leur nouveau logement
je suis là marc fit et je suis ashley
feat nous venons d'oklahoma city et nous
suivons la dernière tendance vivre dans
un logement de poche et acheter une
camionnette on a monté les côtés
je suis un peu nerveuse pour tenir les
délais ok parfait
il nous reste beaucoup à faire dans un
délai très réduit
[Musique]
dans leur van
tout est calculé au millimètre près
chaque matin après avoir habillé leur
fille ils doivent ranger leurs maisons
[Musique]
chaque chose un emplacement précis
c'est comme ça que je les dessine et
pour la plupart des objets je savais
déjà où il devait se ranger
pour faire rentrer toutes les affaires
de la famille les filles ont fait preuve
d'ingéniosité y a des placards partout
jusque sous les planchers
on se partage tous les trois oranges
mans ici deux petites boîtes à jouer en
s'installant dans le vallon a établi une
règle avec ma fille ce qui ne rentre pas
dans ces boîtes elle ne peut pas les
garder et quand on va dans un magasin de
jouets elle se débrouille toujours pour
en trouver de petits elle me dit maman
ça ça peut rentrer dans notre vannes les
journées du couple sont elles aussi très
organisé ils ont trouvé un travail en
adéquation etc la vie qu'ils ont choisi
une marque de boisson les emplois pour
conduire ces camions publicitaires et
installer des animations à travers tout
le pays c'est à ce prix qu'ils peuvent
financer chacun de leurs voyages
montrent ici on va y aller hockey
regardez un renard vient on va retrouver
sa baby sitter dans la ville d'à côté on
y va d'accord
à chaque étape du voyage les parents
doivent trouver quelqu'un pour garder
leur fille averly
ça c'est vraiment une galère dans la vie
en vannes comme on n'a pas deux maisons
pour accueillir la baby sitter tous les
jours on doit emmener notre fille chez
elle en plus on travaille dans deux ou
trois endroits différents dans une même
journée
grâce à une application h les
sélectionne des baby-sitters de la
région en se fiant recommandations
laissées par d'autres mamans
on est arrivés mashari la petite et vers
l'est est habitué à changer de nounous
chaque semaine et ses parents ont tout
prévu pour qu'elle se sente chez elle
rentre comment ça va tu as apporté ton
vélo mais c'est génial est-ce qu'on va
aller à la plage
vous avez toujours sa crème solaire
n'est ce pas oui madame ok parfait ah
qu'est-ce que je t'aime vient à que je
te fasse un câlin
amuse toi bien
merci beaucoup à plus tard amuse toi
bien
ça va aller pour elle si elle est
habituée elle me dit juste ok ok au
revoir maman tu peux partir s'il avait
été plus capricieuse jamais il aurait pu
choisir de mener cette vie
le couple vit en installant des stands
de promotion pour des marques toute
l'année
ce jour là ils doivent remonter et
installer un présentoir dans un cadre
peu reluisant
je vais demander à l'intérieur où on
doit s'installer une station service en
bordure d'autoroute
il monte des stands plusieurs fois par
jour là c'est une marque de bière qui a
fait appel à leurs services
2 3
attends attends l'autre jour je me suis
retourné le poignet et du coup j'utilise
ce camp parce que c'est vraiment trop
lourd
quelques heures plus tard le couple va
démonter le stand pour l'installer dans
un supermarché à eux deux ils gagnent
1800 euros par mois pour ces deux
diplômes et cette vie de manoeuvre est
le prix à payer pour garder leur liberté
ce n'est pas pour ça que je suis allé à
l'école évidemment
mais c'est un moyen idéal pour voyager
et travailler en voyant du pays
après le boulot les fit ont récupéré
leur fille
cela fait des mois qu'ils parcourent
l'intérieur du pays ils vont enfin
pouvoir fouler le sable de floride
everly
on doit aller voir la mer
tu crois qu'elle est froide qu'elle est
chaude ou qu'elle est juste parfaite
on y est enfin
c'est vraiment génial j'ai six copains
d'être ici cet endroit ça va être notre
maison pour les mois à venir
la famille profite d'habitude des parcs
nationaux pour se garer gratuitement
mes amis amies l'une des villes les plus
chères d'amérique ashley ne sait pas
très bien comment trouver un emplacement
pour la nuit
donc j'ai fait des recherches avant de
venir
on aime improviser mais on aime bien
s'organiser à l'avancé aussi
est le plus gros problème auquel on a
été confrontés c'est que miami est l'une
des villes les plus difficiles
d'amérique pour les campeurs comme nous
il y a beaucoup d'interdiction
d'endroits où l'on ne peut pas se garer
ici rien n'est gratuit
ce soir pas de vue sublime sur la plage
ni de couchers de soleil postée sur
internet
il n'y a pas de place ici c'est la
réalité moins glamour de leur vie nomade
faute d'emplacements libres la famille
termine sur le parking d'un centre
commercial
mais même ici ils ne sont pas toujours
les bienvenus avec leurs vannes un
panneau d'interdiction pour les campeurs
oui le gros problème c'est qu'il n'ya
jamais de panneaux d'interdiction pour
les vans d'habitude et là il y en a pour
la première fois
et les un monsieur qui arrivent en
voiture juste derrière l'autre
non
il arrive je crois qu'il veut te parler
cette zone là elle est interdite au
stationnement
merci monsieur c'est bien compris
la famille est épuisé plutôt que de
chercher un emplacement toute la nuit
ils vont casser leur tirelire une
centaine de dollars pour passer une nuit
tranquille dans un motel
ils ont accepté ce travail pour pouvoir
vivre de nouvelles expériences et être
sans attaches
dès le jour suivant ils ont prévu de
partir à la découverte des plus belles
plages de floride
[Musique]
à l'autre bout du pays au milieu du
désert de mojave dans le colorado
nous retrouvons katie la voyageuse
solitaire avec sa chienne sophie
depuis son départ il ya deux mois elle a
déjà parcouru ces mille kilomètres au
volant de son camion
je me sens beaucoup plus à l'aise que
lorsque j'ai commencé
quand je suis parti mon vannes n'était
pas construit y avait rien
je ne savais pas courant oui comment
faire enfin je ne savais rien
maintenant j'apprends toujours mais tous
ces poussins
elle traverse le parc national des
arches
150 km de route au milieu de ces
immenses formations naturelles en vert
et rose
c'est magnifique
on se sent tout petit quand on voit ces
montagny moss
à côté moi et mon van qu'on est
minuscule
comme prévu elle bricole sa maison en
route en ce moment elle fait les
dernières finitions solelhac de son
plafond son vin des débuts est difficile
à reconnaître
j'ai impressionné pas mal de gens qui
disaient cool
et il pensait tous que j'étais en couple
et ne pensait pas qu'une fille pouvait
faire ça tout seul
terminé le lit pliable désormais elle se
paye le luxe d'un matelas king size
comme chaque nuit ketty a établi son
campement au milieu de nulle part sans
s'inquiéter d'éventuelles mauvaises
rencontres
alors je n'ai pas cette inquiétude
mes parents s'inquiètent parce que je
suis leur enfant
mais par chance je n'ai pas eu de
problème jusqu'à présent
peut-être que je suis naïve mais je n'ai
pas peur
[Musique]
dans son fourgon elle n'a pas encore de
radiateur ni même de réchauds
par zéro degré elle se contentera d'un
repas froid
une vie d'ascète et de solitude en
quittant tout c'est exactement ce
qu'elle recherchait
[Musique]
j'ai décidé de me lancer j'étais
célibataire donc c'était facile
je n'avais aucune attache
est ce que vous pensez on compterait
quelques longs sur l'autre je n'y pense
pas je ne cherche pas trop ça en ce
moment
[Musique]
au réveil elle doit prendre la route
pour aller se laver
pour sa toilette elle a pris un
abonnement dans un réseau de salles de
sport ni vue ni connue elle va se
débarbouiller au milieu des sportifs
dans les toilettes les vestiaires
vous n'avez pas l'impression d'être une
sans domicile fixe dans ces moments là
je ne pense pas ça fait juste partie
d'un style de vie différent
et quand je peux je fais aussi du sport
plutôt que juste prendre une douche et
et repartir
je me lave les cheveux deux fois par
semaine hier j'ai pris une douche
peut-être trois fois par semaine
c'est pas grave c'est plus un pour mes
cheveux quand tu es en vie le tue les
lave tout le temps et une en laisse pas
le temps de respirer
tutti ressemble beaucoup mois à la jeune
fille bourgeoise qui a quitté ses
parents il ya deux mois
ses copines sont les premiers étonnés
par le changement
à l'aéroport de denver il vient chercher
l'insee une amie proche
je vais pleurer
dingue tu dans là dedans tu cuisines
étui vie c'est trop génial parce que
c'est pas ça est-ce que je peux me
joindre à toi pour le reste de ton tour
ouest où on faisait ça va j'arrive pas à
croire que je suis là
contrairement à elle sa copine mines et
vit dans une maison
elle essaye de comprendre le choix du
nouveau style de vie de son ami
qu'est ce qui est le plus dur quand tu
vis dans un van
de ne pas avoir de gazinière
parce que tu ne peux pas cuisiner
j'ai passé mon temps à manger des
avocats et des bananes
[Rires]
je trouve ça cool ou un peu angoissant
parce que tu dois toujours savoir où
aller extra
non non c'est pas se pressent chaque
jour est différent il n'y a pas de
routine et c'est ce que je voulais
jusque là tout a été positif
je pense que tout le monde on a envie
mais vraiment le vivre
que pour passer outre tous les petits
tracas
par exemple ne pas pouvoir faire du café
le matin ça me rendrait sol
après seulement quelques semaines sur
les routes elle n'est déjà plus certaine
de vouloir redevenir sédentaires un jour
en floride la famille fit part explorer
les keys un magnifique chapet dean au
large de miami
un repos bien mérité avec petit budget
système d et en gardons toujours le sens
rien
[Musique]
on pourrait facilement se plaindre dire
oh je suis pauvre je me douche dans des
parkings ou alors tu peux dire ah je
vais rentrer sans permission dans ce
stade municipal pour aller me doucher et
ça c'est vraiment marrant et donc on
essaye de se mettre dans un état
d'esprit où tout est rigolo
et le plus grand océan que j'ai jamais
vu
oui je sais c'est fou regarde l'eau et
turquoise
pour ces quelques jours de vacances ils
se sont offert un petit plaisir ce
camping avec une magnifique vue sur la
baie
il ya de l'eau partout l'on regarde tu
le vois
oui il ya de l'eau partout à l'horizon
depuis que la famille a vendu sa maison
il ya trois ans chaque jour il faut
faire la cuisine sur une petite
gazinière de camping
mais il assume très bien ce style de vie
naumann plus en phase avec le monde
moderne selon eux
notre génération elle dit je peux
travailler sur la route et voyager et je
peux voir toutes les choses
merveilleuses qu'il y avoir avant de
prendre ma retraite parce que nous
n'avons pas le temps parce que nous ne
savons pas si on vivra assez longtemps
pour profiter de notre retraite ou
d'être en assez bonne santé pour en
profiter alors autant le faire
maintenant
et pour l'école les parents utilisent
les nouvelles technologies 1 4 ans et
wehrli n'a jamais connu de classes
maternelles une application wisair
d'instituteurs regarde ma main très bien
bravo si tu termines tout le programme
de la première section de maternelle qui
aura droit à un gâteau une tarte au
citron
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup davantage à
s'impliquer dans l'éducation de ses
enfants
et ça c'est plus compliqué quand vous
avez un travail de bureau
et que vous ne passez pas beaucoup de
temps avec vos enfants
j'ai des amis qui font ça très bien mais
pour nous cette vie nous correspond
beaucoup mieux
[Musique]
cet après midi au programme les eaux
transparentes de l'archipel
quatre jours de travail pour trois jours
de vacances c'est comme ça qu'ils vivent
toute l'année ils prennent le large vers
la baie de floride
la marque va plonger pour la toute
première fois de sa vie il a négocié un
bon prix avec un pêcheur du coin
[Musique]
j'ai tellement hâte est tellement fort
en même temps mais j'ai surtout hâte
[Musique]
de quoi se changer les idées après des
jours à monter et à démonter des stands
dans les supermarchés
[Musique]
ah c'était tellement génial oh mon dieu
formidable
je voudrais être un poisson
je pense que j'étais faite pour vivre
sous l'eau comme une sirène
dans un an ou deux la famille songe à
s'opposer trouver une école primaire
pour leur fille le van ce sera juste
pour les vacances
quand nous aurons une maison dans le
futur on aura toujours un vin
et on s'y sentira comme chez nous
on pourra partir sur la route aussi
longtemps qu'on voudra et on aura notre
maison avec sauf que tous les soirs on
regardera le coucher du soleil depuis un
endroit différent
depuis notre tournage corée et emilie
ont parcouru plus de 3000 km et traversé
11 états du nord au sud de l'amérique
toujours en pratiquant du yoga sur la
route ils ont de plus en plus d'abonnés
[Musique]
dans le désert de la sierra nevada en
californie
alan élise les deux retraités baroudeur
touche enfin à leurs objectifs
[Musique]
les fameuses dunes d'eurêka haute de 200
m
on apprécie tellement plus ses moments
après une vie passée à travailler dur et
parfois quand on y repense on en rigole
en france at-on concours art vingt ans
peut-être même 30
le phénomène n'en est qu'à ses débuts et
devrait s'amplifier
10 millions de foyers américains
possèdent déjà leurs vannes prêt à
prendre la route
[Musique]